ah
toda mi vida crecí con un perfil muy
específico de cómo era yo no todos
decían que yo era de carácter fuerte que
era la líder
la verdad sí me gustaba la atención me
gustaba el control yo decidía quién
podía jugar y qué no
creo que en ese camino llega a ser
bastante cruel e inclusive fui bastante
bullying y marcó lo perfecto de un día
que fui a al cine a ver una película que
se llama las ventajas de ser invisible
que trata sobre niños bueno adolescentes
que son diferentes y que batallan mucho
en una sociedad que exige que todos
seamos iguales y toda la película me
acordé mucho de una compañía en
específico que tuve en primaria y
secundaria
pues yo mal estaba mucho
y saliendo del cine yo ya era mamá ya
tenía a mis dos hijos mayores
y saliendo decidí escribirle a la
contacte por por las redes sociales y le
pedí perdón perdón no sé si si realmente
es algo que te afectó no sé si te
acuerdas
por qué lo tengo muy vivo dentro de mí
que se dice daño
y no te lo mereces te quiero pedir una
disculpa
mientras yo vaya esta película me
acordaba de eso y me da terror de que
mis hijos tuvieran una compañera como yo
que triste no o que se convirtieran en
lo que yo era
entonces
en ese instante yo decidí cambiar la
narrativa que venía arrastrando desde
hace 25 años yo no quería hacer esa
persona no quería que me viera la gente
sino quería que mis hijos me vieran así
y así no era como yo quería tratar a las
personas entonces en ese instante decidí
cambiar mi narrativa a cambiar la
persona que venía haciendo
y creo que algo similar te pasa cuando
eres papá cuando te convierte en mamá
guapa cambias involuntariamente pero
cambias te transformas en otro ser
humano no eres diferente y me ha pasado
con mis tres hijos no he cambiado de
diferentes maneras con los tres pero
nunca en mi vida dimensiones el cambio
que iba a tener desde que nació mi hijo
luca que es el mayor
luca es un niño siempre fue un niño muy
deseado fue un embarazo planeado
el primer nieto el primer sobrino el
primer hijo de mis amigas
fue un embarazo perfecto sin
complicaciones un parto normal todo fue
muy bien un poco menos de un año después
nace mi segunda hija eugenia
y todo iba muy bien la familia feliz y
como al año ocho meses de luca
empezamos a notar
diferencias en su desarrollo empezamos a
notar que si era diferente que los demás
niños
no hablaba cuando le
llamadas por su nombre no te voltea a
ver parecía no entender lo que yo le
decían las instrucciones que le daban
y poco a poco nos empezamos a preocupar
al principio pensé que era porque había
nacido su hermana y después nos
empezamos a preocupar y empezamos a
buscar qué estaba pasando conmigo
por casi dos años
buscamos diagnósticos buscamos alguna
explicación de qué era lo que estaba
pasando qué podíamos hacer al respecto
en méxico nadie me lo quiso diagnosticar
y no fue hasta que nos fuimos a vivir a
españa donde ya me dijeron tu hijo tiene
autismo todo este proceso de dos años
que vivimos todo lo que yo recuerdo y yo
creo que me dijeron era todo lo negativo
no todo lo que no iba a ser mi hijo todo
lo que no iba a lograr
prácticamente me dijeron tu vida es
completamente diferente que como lo
habías pensado
entonces cuando me enteré del nombre de
el evento de hoy
y supe lo que significa me regresé a ese
momento del diagnóstico y me acuerdo
perfecto que yo lo primero que pensé es
cómo le hago para curar a mi hijo cómo
le hago para quitarle esto tan negativo
que que me están diciendo que tiene
entonces nuestra generación tiene mucho
acceso a la información no estamos a un
clic de
distancia de cualquier tipo de
información y puede ser positivo puede
ser negativo
el autismo tiene mucha información y
tiene dos caminos muy específicos el
camino de querer curar a tu hijo que va
a cambiar lo que debe hacer lo normal o
el camino de aceptar esta
diversidad neurológica que tiene y
ayudarlo a cumplir su potencial
en un principio me fui por el primer
camino yo decía cómo le hago para que
esto no existe en él
y cosas que me encontré en internet que
me encontré por todos lados es una
terapia que se usa mucho en todo el
mundo
de hecho en eeuu es la que te acepta el
seguro
el creador de esta terapia
dijo esta frase que se me quedó muy
marcada siempre dice verás comienzas
prácticamente desde cero cuando trabajas
con un niño autista tienes una persona
en el sentido físico tienen pelo tiene
nariz tienen boca pero no son personas
en el sentido psicológico una forma de
ver el trabajo de ayudar a los niños con
autismo es verlo como una cuestión de
construir una persona tiene la materia
prima pero tienes que construir a la
persona imagínense que esto es lo
primero que lees después de recibir un
diagnóstico como el autismo
obviamente yo dije pues que tengo que
hacer para construir a mí
creo que es
un camino muy oscuro por el que te lleva
a leer algo así
hoy después de siete años justo
cumplimos siete años de que
diagnosticaron a mi hijo le diría a este
señor con toda la certeza de mi ser que
está completamente equivocado mi hijo no
se necesita construir mi hijo no está
roto mi hijo jamás estuvo roto después
de tantos años yo me doy cuenta que lo
que está roto es el sistema médico el
sistema de educación la sociedad y la
que estaba rota era yo
y todo empieza desde que estamos
chiquitos aún antes de ser papás
crecemos con una red con una narrativa
de cómo tenemos que ser como mujeres
como miembros de una sociedad tenemos
que casarnos tener hijos que nuestros
hijos vayan a las mejores escuelas hay
gente que inscribe a sus hijos a la
escuela aún antes de que nazcan porque
tienen que ir a esas escuelas
tienen que ser buenos estudiantes tienen
que sobresalir tiene que ser deportistas
lo que quieras
yo me acuerdo que cuando yo me casé con
mi esposo él era jugador profesional de
fútbol entonces obviamente nosotros aún
antes de embarazarme sabíamos que
nuestro primer hijo tenía que ser niño
si nos embaraza moss y nos enteramos que
luca era niño le compramos todas las
camisas de fútbol que existen en el
planeta no importaba si llegamos o no
todos los de fútbol después muy
considerado dijimos bueno la mejor y no
le gusta el fútbol entonces compramos
las de básquet y compramos las de fútbol
américano las de béisbol el niño iba a
ser deportista profesional no importaba
lo que estaba pasando el yo ser
deportista profesional imagínense la
gravedad de eso no que aún antes de
embarazar nos
ya había decidido cuál iba a ser el sexo
de mi hijo cómo iba a ser el cómo cómo
iba a ser su vida entonces cuando
recibes un diagnóstico como el autismo
que te viene a decir no no todo lo que
tienes planeado no va a existir
vos te deprimes te reprimas no quiere
saber nada quieres cambiar a tu hijo y
empezamos a pensar que el niño tiene un
problema cuando en verdad los que
tenemos el problema somos nosotros yo
fuimos a muchísimos doctores con
muchísimos pero el que más mejor desde
el primer hito con el que fuimos me
acuerdo perfecto de la sala de espera
era un instituto nacional de
rehabilitación entonces se podrán
imaginar como como el lugar
estuvimos esperando dos horas cuando ya
pasamos al consultorio me acuerdo
perfecto el consultorio era alargada
rectangular me acuerdo perfecto del tono
de la voz del doctor era extranjero
y lo vio lo que a mí se me hicieron que
fueron cinco minutos han de haber sido
unos quince minutos
y no dudó en decirme todo lo que estaba
mal conmigo a mi parecer existen cinco
áreas del desarrollo tu hijo está mal en
las cinco su hijo nunca va a hablar
quizás nunca te va a decir mamá tu hijo
no va a poder hacer las tareas básicas
de un ser humano no va a poder ni doblar
tu ropa esos son sus palabras
tu hijo no va a ir a una escuela regular
en tu hijo nunca va a querer socializar
todo todo lo negativo me lo dijo así no
no no la verdad es que lucas tenía un
año ocho meses cuando seguimos con este
doctor y yo no había investigado nada yo
no no tenía idea de que algo negativo
estaría pasando con mi hijo entonces él
y en shock yo ni me acuerdo si me
despedí del doctor o no agarré a mi hijo
y me fui no voltea atrás y jamás volvió
a ese lugar
y siempre me como pensar como ve ha sido
de diferente mi proceso porque esto fue
el principio de estos dos años que
siguen como ha sido diferente si desde
un inicio me hubieran cambiado la
narrativa porque tiene que ser una
narrativa tan negativa desde un inicio
y entonces en vez de decirme tu hijo
nunca hablar quizá no te llama más
puedes decir tu hijo tiene una retraso
en el lenguaje no sabemos si va a poder
hablar pero existen diferentes tipos de
comunicación alternativa que puedes usar
para comunicarte con tu hijo eso es lo
importante comunicarte con tu hijo que
me digan eso desde el principio mucha
gente desperdicia muchos años de su vida
con terapias que nunca van a hacer su
hijo hablado porque no les dicen que lo
importante es la comunicación
tu hijo no va a poder doblar su propia
ropa tu hijo va a batallar
las tareas básicas no va a ser tan fácil
enseñarle pero con mucha dedicación y
mucha constancia lo puede lograr porque
si lo pueden lograr
tu hijo nunca va a poder una escuela
regular se pueden decir quizás no todos
los modelos educativos encajen con tu
hijo hay diferentes maneras pueden tener
adaptaciones curriculares pueden ir con
un acompañante o es existen escuelas
especializadas y tampoco está mal no
esto también es un tabú que que forman
al ser tan negativos tu hijo no vas a
querer socializar quizás tu hijo va a
batallar para socializar de hecho va a
ser de los retos más grandes que va a
tener pero puedes ayudarlo y crearle
ambientes para que aprenda a socializar
creo que esta narrativa ha sido muy
distinta
para para mí para cualquier mamá o papá
que reciben un diagnóstico así porque ya
en vez de buscar eliminar algo busca es
construir algo en vez de estar sufriendo
vives vives lo que tienes enfrente
yo creo que nosotros tenemos el control
de la narrativa que queremos contar y
así como alguien hace años decidió que
la narrativa del autismo iba a ser
negativa yo decido que no en mi vida no
va a ser negativa pues cuando yo tomo
esta decisión y realmente cambió la
manera en que yo veo el autismo y veo a
mi hijo
empiezan a pasar cosas
que no me esperaba que me sorprenden
todos los días al fin tuve esta conexión
con mi hijo que
debería tener cualquier mamá con un hijo
empezamos a mejorar todos como familia
estábamos el mismo canal nunca nunca
empezó a ir muy bien en la escuela
empezó a avanzar empezó a hablar
todo iba muy bien nosotros estábamos
disfrutando al hijo que tenemos enfrente
vivíamos en ese momento en querétaro y
nos vamos a vivir a la ciudad de mexico
y yo estaba segura que iba encontrarles
por de mi hijo en la ciudad de méxico
tienes que vivir y estudiar en la misma
zona porque si no es imposible entonces
ya sabía la escuela específica a la que
iban visitas cuando hablo y le digo hola
quiero ir a conocer su escuela tengo un
hijo autista que van con nuestra sombra
me dicen con este tono
we know no señorita aquí no aceptamos
niños autistas aceptamos niños síndrome
down con parálisis cerebral y after me
dijo esa palabra pero niños autistas no
y además aunque tú puedas la maestra
sombra también representa un costo para
nosotros porque se toma nuestro café y
usa nuestro estacionamiento
y yo me quedé en shock yo dije no me
está contestando es esta señora es broma
obviamente serví por dentro y le
contesté le dije
como la persona que contesta el teléfono
una escuela inclusiva tiene que saber
qué hacer no se dice así es asperger y
que es lo mismo que autismo es entonces
tienes que estar un poco más informada y
exploté nunca pensando lo que me ha
pasado después pero
y me dijo si quieres hablamos con la
directora y dije no no no esta escuela
no es para mi hijo gracias
después de eso estuve buscando escuelas
la verdad me las había considerado hable
a 23 escuelas en la ciudad de mexico 21
me dijeron no tu hijo autista no podía
aquí no conocieron a mi hijo solo
conocían su etiqueta porque no
conocieron a mi hijo ninguna estas
veintiuna escuelas y me decían no somos
inclusivos no nos interesa ser
inclusivos autistas no porque autistas
no porque
un señor hace 70 años decidió cómo iba a
vivir mi vida pero en la vida mi hijo
hoy por qué porque está en una narrativa
incorrecta de lo que es el autismo
entonces te aceptan todo menos autismo
porque no sabemos que no sabemos qué
hacer
yo creo que qué
nuestras diferencias es lo que más nos
ha dividido como humanidad diferencias
políticas religiosas
culturales hasta las deportivas nos
dividen y para mí la diversidad de
mentes viene a unirnos viene
a unir todas estas piezas rotas de la
sociedad para para recordarnos que se
necesitan diferentes tipos de mentes
para evolucionar para mejorar cuando yo
recibo el diagnóstico de mi hijo sentí
que me lo habían quitado y sentí que me
hayan quitado a mi hijo y hoy después de
tantos años les puedo decir que ese es
el día que conocí a mi hijo el día que
me dieron el diagnóstico y me sentí
culpable muchísimo tiempo porque por
tres años y medio no trate a mi hijo
como lo que era yo lo trataba como una
ilusión que no existe algo que yo
pensaba que tenía que ser pero ahora
después decir que me siento orgulloso de
todo lo que viví y justo el quid sung y
soy yo y luca es la resina y el oro que
me vinieron a reconstruir me hicieron
mejor mamá mejor ser humano
mejor mujer y yo siempre voy a estar
agradecida de recibir algo así en mi
vida
a mí me dijeron que el lugar nunca iba a
querer mirar
[Música]
bueno
nunca iba a hablar y al principio no
hablaba se comunicaba por medio de la
imagen
[Aplausos]
quiero globo
con muchísimo esfuerzo logrado sacar una
palabra
yo soy al final
y hoy domingo
quien te ama más que yo
dispuesto está empezó a cantar
y yo
de público
querido
[Música]
aprendió levico en todos los vídeos más
que existen
[Música]
la manera en la que elegimos ahorrar
nuestra vida
no
[Música]